Columbia as you all know is building a
new campus down to Manhattan Ville and
the first building built is a huge
commitment to what they call mind brain
and behavior just supposed to sort of
find out how people actually operate one
of the endearing but also horrible
things about 19th century thought was
how many innovative thoughts were
entertained on the basis of virtually no
no hard knowledge and speculation me you
know once it was repeated enough and
acquired disciples speculations of the
most unlikely sort came to be thought by
many people to be truths and those that
I'm interested in today are those that
deal with one of the hardest topics for
contemporary historians to deal with and
that is human inequality oddly enough if
you go back to historians of 200 years
ago from the early 19th century they
have very few problems with human
inequality it was manifest and it didn't
bother them very much they might think
that slavery was a bad idea
for various reasons but that did not
mean that they ascribed equality to
those people who were enslaved Abraham
Lincoln for example was strongly in
favor of having the African
American slave population repatriated to
Africa he did not think that they were
assimil in the United States because
they were different we now have a pretty
much at universal commitment in this
country though not worldwide to the
notion of equality although it is time
and again inequality that has to be
appraised with respect to some sort of
norm for example is it it should there
be an equality of riches you know or
should there be an equality of
opportunity so that people are free to
be poor or rich according to their
opportunity should there be an equality
of color or gender or any number of
things and the issue of difference is
now perhaps as vexing as any that we
have because there are incompatibilities
between the assumption of equality and
people's perception of the real world if
you go back to 1800 the real world
trumped philosophy people said there was
inequality and they often imputed to it
a certain scientific substance I have a
book for example entitled Negro mania
it's published around 1800 and what it
is is a collection of articles meant to
to show the stupidity of people who
claimed that Africans were equal to
white people and they were from some of
the most distinguished natural ists and
philosophers and thinkers of the time
because everybody
you know had some interest in the topic
and it was felt that the argument for
equality was preposterous it was a
fanatic fringe view that any
right-thinking person observing the real
world would repudiate but when you look
at the notions of inequality that you
had in 1800 they're very different from
the notions of inequality that you have
in 1900 and it's that change that comes
in this period of the late nineteenth
century that this chapter and the new
Power Balance is devoted to that I want
to talk about and it is the change that
we generally label as social Darwinism
in 1800 you had in the scientific world
particularly of Natural Science
observational science you had a passion
for for classification this goes back at
least to the 17th century in some
respects to the 16th and it was
manifested in the desire to give every
species of plant or animal a scientific
name that would distinguish it from
every other species and to classify
those species with him
within families within general so you
had a you had an individual animal it
would belong to a species the species
would belong to a genus the genus would
belong to an order to a phylum etcetera
and you had a great sort of tree like
structure of all of all being botanist
zoologists entomologists were fascinated
by classification and some of the most
famous scientists the time were known
for the collections I had in their
identification of previously unknown
Plast animals this was something that as
I say it's largely 16th century because
it was the the European travels in
foreign parts the new world and the the
parts of Asia that they reached by
sailing around Africa that stimulated
them to to create these these
classifications and to try and put
everything into some sort of an order
humans of course were then subjected to
the same sort of classification if you
had humans who looked as different say
as a rose looked from a tulip it's
dealing strictly on a visual basis then
how could one not classify the humans
you could classify them according to
appearances you know hair color or
texture skin color shape of the skull
stature abilities to do certain things
and seeming disabilities to do other
things and of course in this
classification as in all of the others
you have an enormous amount of of
arbitrariness and I think it's one of
the things that that have taken
generations to iron out is the question
of whether classifications of organisms
are our sound or whether they are or
were they simply notional when Linnaeus
the Swedish botanist who for whom we
have from whom we have borrowed our
practice of giving
three part names two species carl
linnaeus was interested particularly in
classification of plants and he he wrote
out in very highly sexualized terms
depending on the the number of stamens
that a plant had so you'd have a well
you'd have some plants that were
sexually differentiated with the female
plant in a male plant like date trees
others would have one pistol in one
stamen they're sort of monogamous and
you had the bigamist plants that have
two stamens and finally you get up to
sort of gangbang plants where you have a
lot of staples and in the 17th century
there were people who were concerned
that young ladies in england should not
study botany because it was a science
that bordered on depravity and this was
largely because of Linnaeus's decision
to classify things according to number
of stamens and them to to characterise
the classifications so the
classifications were always to some
degree suppositions or conjectural and
the same thing with humans how many
races were there how many different
types of people were there well how do
you how do you label them how do you
classify them
this kind of thinking by the time you
get to say to the middle of the 19th
century is beginning to sort of
metastasize very unfortunate ways
because new currents of scientific
thought or what passed a scientific
thought come to be common and those new
currents seek to to apply science to
this classification of people's as
opposed to applying simply description
in other words you could have Linnaeus
who is looking at the number of staples
of the stamens or someone else who's
counting the number of ribs or something
like that that's sort of descriptive
science but when you got in the late
19th century sought to be more more
scientific by being more engaged with
theory and with what we're thought of
perhaps as natural laws or what proposes
as natural laws the the governing view
in this later part of the century
and certainly the this this period of
cyant izing difference applies in a
number of fields it isn't simply a
matter of race this is the period when
you get the the idea that gender
preferences are scientific differences
that someone who is homosexual falls
into this category someone who is
heterosexual that category and you know
been trying to explain this in
scientific terms
or the science of psychology where you
try to explain differences of mind
according to some notion of of
scientific theory this is when Freud e
Freudian psychology takes us roots out
of biology and and in all of these
things you know there there's almost a
dearth of what would now pass as science
so the key thing for the division of
people's that particular aspect of late
19th century science was a notion of
evolution evolution associated with
Charles Darwin although it was jointly
the the conjecture that we call natural
selection was jointly arrived at as I've
mentioned before in this class by Darwin
and Wallace working independently social
Darwinism is the term used for the idea
that evolutionary theory
natural selection applies to differences
among social groups up to the level of
of races and down to the level of simply
nationalities or localities in the same
way that it applies to to plants or
animals oddly enough social Darwinism
was not a term that was used in the late
19th century in fact the term rarely
occurs I think the first appearance of
the is used once I think around 1877 but
it rarely occurs in any literature at
all until 1944
and the person who who put social
darwinism on the map was a member of the
Columbia history department Richard
Hofstadter in 1944 he wrote a book
called social Darwinism in America from
that time on a label was available to
talk about things that were considered
particularly pernicious and and
unscientific about late 19th century
thought so some people have said well
did Hofstadter invent social Darwinism
not really we're actually does exist but
it was rarely used until hope chatter
did it and he associated social
Darwinism with one particular thinker
Herbert Spencer philosopher ooh died in
1903 and who never used the word social
Darwinism nor was the word social of
Darwinism ever used for him until
Hofstadter came along Spencer thus
becomes sort of one of the great goats
of history when you read a let's say a
typical world history textbook let's say
the earth and the people and its peoples
on the chapter on the new Power Balance
you'll find social Darwinism attached to
the name of Herbert Spencer who never
actually you know probably ever heard
the term other textbooks some of them
use herbert spencer's name in particular
and others simply discuss social
Darwinism as if it were a
that were that was actually recognized
say in the sense of Darwin as it was
nobody denies that Darwinism was a
buzzword and a very important and
controversial one
in the late 19th century just that
social Darwinism was not Herbert Spencer
was the best-selling philosopher perhaps
in the history of England his books are
estimated to have sold over a million
copies during his lifetime he was not a
professor indeed he was not educated at
Oxford or Cambridge he was an autodidact
who had done some learning at home he
had a smattering of Latin but did not
have the classical education that was
normal for Englishmen who were in the
the upper crust but he was sort of
adopted into the the intellectual circle
of Thomas Huxley Huxley who of course
you know a member of a long-standing
intellectual family you know we have you
know various other Huxley's coming down
to recent times and was a pillar of sort
of Oxford Cambridge intelligentsia
Huxley probably was the one who coined
the word Darwinism because when Darwin
received the essay from Wallace that
contained all of the theories of natural
selection he wrote he wrote to or spoke
with Huxley and said now he must give up
my last 14 years of work because you
know somebody beat me to it
and Huxley said don't know we will fix
up a meeting we will read your MIT
we all read Wallace's material and
people will see that you have these
ideas first even though you didn't
publish them and then Huxley proceeded
to call the theory Darwinism which was
fine with Wallace because as a
autodidact someone who didn't have these
high credentials he was happy simply be
included in that in that cleek and so
was Spencer you know by being a friend
of Huxley's and being invited to club
meetings and dinner parties you know he
did he met George Eliot he met you know
eminent figures of the time and he was a
person of eccentric and little educated
background and yet his book sold like
hotcakes
and he made his living writing his
philosophy books know it's interesting
you think now could somebody really
become a celebrity as a philosopher with
no particular educational background and
of course the answer is yes because we
we have the figure of Eric Hoffer who
wrote the true believer which became a
very widely read book about fanaticism
and had no impressive educational
credentials to write it but when you
have an example a case of someone like
Hoffer or Herbert Spencer what you see
is that there are people who find that
particular philosophy instrumental in
terms of their own agendas which they
hold as members of a more elite class
than the particular individual so
Spencer
was ballyhooed by an intelligent CEO
that he did not fully belong to never
married had no children did not create
any any succession there was no
Spencerian school philosophy but he was
terribly successful and he is he is
thought to have originated the phrase
survival of the fittest which never
occurs in Darwin's writings the thing is
Spencer's views on human difference are
have almost nothing to do with Darwin or
Darwin's theory of evolution and social
Darwinism has almost nothing to do with
Darwin or with Darwin's theories of
natural selection and evolution
Spencer was coming out of a very
different tradition that goes back more
to Thomas Malthus who was the
philosopher who wrote about the
inevitable overpopulation of the earth
and everyone dying of starvation or to
oghuz Comte who was a positivist and
said that you know with you know
leadership of scientific thought
everything will become better and better
Spencer preached the idea of progress
that everything was going to become
better and he used a notion of evolution
because the idea of evolution as a word
that is say the use of the word
evolution for for systemic change
predated Darwin natural selection was
something that Darwin and Wallace came
up with but evolution was a word that
was already there for say two
generations or more before
in you know in scientific terms compared
with Darwin Spencer followed a late
eighteenth-century thinker named Lamarck
ah and the mark ISM is often contrasted
with Darwinism there - yeah they are
Lamarque believed that let's say if you
had a dog that you trained to be a great
sheep herder that the puppies of that
dog produced would be better sheep
herders than the puppies produced by
another dog that had never been exposed
to sheep herding because the skills that
were acquired during the lifetime of the
of the sheep herding dog would be
transferred genetically to to the
puppies
Spencer applied this to to humans so
humans as they become as they know more
as they become better as they gain
greater control of the universe around
them they pass this on to their children
in evolutionary terms let us say the
children are born smarter more able and
this is the inheritance of acquired
characteristics one thing it's important
to remember is that no one in the 19th
century had the foggiest notion of what
inheritance amounted to it was not even
known for example throughout I think
right up to the end of the 19th century
that that mammals had had eggs and I
think the human over
was identified in the early 20th century
the idea that there would be there had
to be some sort of mechanism of
inheritance was barely thought of people
didn't know about genes obviously didn't
know about DNA they had no idea of what
the mechanics of inheritance were and
they tended to simply go on a on an
assumption that what you had in a parent
animal would carry over into the into
the offspring in not undiminished form
but in a form that you could predict
when you go into eighteenth-century
animal issues and to some degree yet
back into 17th century you'll find that
all of this is strongly associated with
the idea of reading this is when
scientific breeding so-called became a
craze in certain areas particularly
among the the British elite people for
example will go back now and look at how
many breeds of dog were there in England
in 1600 so look at information on dogs
maybe well there appear to be maybe six
and then you get to nineteen hundred and
you have like 125 you know how did you
go from having a you know a very short
list having very long list over two
centuries in time and of course the
breeders could tell you because they
were selecting characteristics to be
transferred genetically although they
had no idea what genetically meant
transferred by inheritance from the from
the adult to the to the offspring
that this was all conceived of within an
economic framework so that there would
be financial advantage to to creating a
or perfecting a breed or a variety and
there was a craze for particularly fat
cows and fat pigs where at fairs you
would bring some humongously heavy cow
or pig and exhibited and the weight
would be published and it would be
celebrated and then it would be killed
and butchered and you would get to eat
this really really really fatty meat
because more fat was considered better
but the breeders knew that selecting for
particular characteristics like super
abundant fat was not consistent that it
might work for two or three generations
what they called in and in breeding was
where you would have let's say a fat cow
and you would made it with a fat bull
and then it would have calves then you
would have the the calf the male calf
would be bred with the mother and the
female with the father and you would in
breed as much as possible in order to
maximize the characters of the original
of the original parents and in an
inbreeding did produce in the first
generation or to know a significant
number of really really fat fat animals
but then defects began to show up and
people began to realize that that you
had to have some breeding diversity even
though I had no idea what the mechanism
was Mendel and his theories of his
experiments with pea plants showing
the laws of inheritance was still a
century century and a half away so
sometimes you would get a clever breeder
who would breed an extremely fat animal
through in and inbreeding for two or
three generations and then sell it to
you know Lord so-and-so as a as a bull
for his livestock realizing the next
generation was going to be full of ruts
and phoebs and that it wasn't going to
to pan out because the breeders knew a
tremendous amount from their from their
practical experiences they knew it with
large animals of the level horses and
pigs and cows they developed breeds of
sheep for different qualities of wool
and so forth and eventually they knew it
for smaller animals particularly Oh
chickens Canaries ducks dogs cats so
forth and so on
pigeons rats breeding became a
fascinating hobby and the people who
actually superintended the breeding
tended to be people from sort of
working-class backgrounds but they were
often patronized or their products were
bought by the elite they didn't keep
records except in particularly the cases
of big animals like horses and cattle so
they could produce new strains of
animals without anyone really having any
record of how those strains came about
one of the most frequently queried
examples is where did laboratory rats
come from sometime in the 19th century
scientists started to use
albino rats in laboratory experiments
because they were you
they didn't bite you they were docile
you could you know chop off their limbs
or inject them with substances do
whatever you wanted I mean it was just a
lab rat but it was very different wild
rat wild rat is a nasty animal that you
don't want to to handle but but the
white rats were fine and yet nobody knew
where the white rats had come from so
you had different thoughts one of them
and probably as close to being right is
that they derive from the practice of
ratting whereby you have rat collectors
who would go out and collect 50 or 100
wild rats on the streets of London put
them in a in a gunnysack take them to a
pit where you would have someone's
Terrier and then you would release 50
rats and you would time how long it took
the terrier to kill all of the rats and
you would bet on that and ranting
competitive you know killing of rats
what was a craze for the for the for the
sporting set back late nineteenth early
late 18th early twentieth century early
19th century now among the rats they
collected there probably were some well
buy no rats because they'll buy an
albinism is a characteristic that you
find among rats and most other wild
animals there are some albinos that get
born just as are among humans but by and
large
they don't live to reproduce because you
know here you are in a dangerous
predatory environment and you're saying
look I am Snow White and the nearest
hawk or owl says yeah you sure are you
just stand out like a flag your lunch
and so the albinos would rarely survive
partly because they were white and
partly because albinos by and large
appear to be extremely docile animals
you which meant that they were not good
for the ratting business no you want a
wrap you dump it out in the bag the
Terrier they're barking and yapping and
the rat goes runs all over the you know
tries to get away and then the terrier
comes and breaks its neck and everyone
applaud where you don't want a rat that
comes out of the back of this gee look
at all the people around know that a dog
if it just isn't
isn't right so it's thought that the
white rats were kept aside by the
breeders by their adders as pets more or
less and then they found that when they
bred the white rats with one another
they had a strain of white rats that
they could sell because they were they
sold them for docility while they were
selling the truly wild rats because of
their excitability so in both cases
you're at a commercial got a commercial
situation yet for all of the breeding
that was done of all sorts of animals
no-one ever produced something that was
called a species it's very difficult to
define a species even down to the
present day you cannot define it
according to whether you have enter
breeding because you have various
species that impact will interbreed
lions and tigers
for example horses and donkeys
but by-and-large interbreeding is your
most common defining characteristic and
no one has created a breed of animal
that is unable to produce offspring with
the parent population that it comes from
so you can think well okay we have a
chihuahua and a Great Dane it's hard to
see them mating and yet if you were to
were to to bring the ovum of a Great
Dane in contact with the sperm of a
Chihuahua
you would produce a dog you wouldn't you
wouldn't find that they were
incompatible now we realize that this
has to do with the number of genes with
the DNA etc etc but what was somewhat
surprising was that animals in the wild
tended to look very much like one
another if they belong to the same
species whereas deliberately bred
animals looked very different from one
another so just as a Chihuahua looks
different from a from a Great Dane so as
people thought about people this became
something of a condom our humans a
species and if they are a species can
all humans interbreed with one another
and in fact does that matter supposing
they can maybe it's like the lion and
the tiger and that they're different
species but they do interbreed and then
you say well but when we look at a
cross-section of humans we find that
they look very different from one
another but do they look different from
one another after the fashion of
chihuahuas and Great Danes or after the
fashion of say no Wolverines and foxes
No
is the difference a species difference
or the difference of breed and there was
a difference a breed how could you how
would you how could you understand that
one of the things that that occurred to
people certainly by the time of Darwin
was that if you could breed animals for
characteristics you could breed humans
for characteristics and you could say
well supposing we want to have
monstrously fat humans if we get a
monstrously fat mother and made her with
an Australian fat father we'll get a
really really chubby baby why you would
want to do that as I'm clear because you
don't have a market incentive there's no
big market for really fat babies on the
other hand there might be a market for
extremely tall people in an era of
basketball playing and of course this is
what has been suggested for the People's
Republic of China that they have engaged
in in breeding experiments to try and
produce exceptionally tall people this
practice is generally known as eugenics
basically Elle is breached for good so
it's good genes essentially and that
word was coined by Darwin's cousin
Francis Galton he advocated that there
should be a general sort of societal
effort to breed better people it never
became instrumentalized
on a large scale although there appear
to have been efforts in Nazi Germany
to do this there were some experiments
or at least thoughts the United States
there was even a movie that came out
devoted to the two eugenic thinking I
have never seen the movie I have not
found anyone who ever has seen the movie
but it was called the Black Swan and if
anyone ever has access to it I would
like to find out because my my
grandfather bought the the syndication
about syndication but the publicity
rights to the Black Swan back in you
know 1909 or something like that so I
always grew up in the basement we had a
big poster for the Black Swan I had no
idea what it was but it's the one movie
that was made about eugenics in America
yeah and and this became a serious issue
what do you do about people who are poor
examples of humanity who insist on
breeding Darwin talked about this
Spencer talked about this Carlton talked
about this this was a very big issue and
in fact it goes back to Malthus as well
here you had people from the most
successful and prosperous straight of
society saying wouldn't it be good if
people who have inferior characteristics
stopped reading the flip side of that
was is there when you recognize that in
Summit we're very explicit I think was
it was Darwin it may been called him who
said that no no property owner would
allow an inferior dog to breed or an
inferior horse you
simply would you know castrate them or
prevent them from breeding because
everyone who actually interacted with
animals in the 19th century knew a lot
about breeding and they simply wouldn't
wouldn't permit it for inferior animals
and so they said well why would we
permit it for inferior humans the
response to that that you got from
people like Darwin or that intellectual
set was that it would be wrong because
they're humans but what should we do
then about inferior humans they said
well we should have welfare and we
should recognize a social commitment to
to ensuring that people of limited
genetic background are not left by the
wayside by my society and they said this
that this is that this grows out of
humane concerns that are certain
important point humane concerns that are
in themselves a product of evolution so
that humane concerns of humans for other
humans would be distinguished in this
respect perhaps to some degree from
humane concerns of humans for animals so
you get a problem in here that this is
when the humane society and various
movements for protection of animals and
so forth are gaining clientele in a very
mixed response to this some people say
you know you should relieve the
suffering of the poor but that doesn't
mean that you should then you should not
put down animals that are
unproductive or defective or use them
for experiment the humane movement
splits at the end of the 19th century
over the issue of vivisection because
many people who favored humane treatment
of animals made an exception for
scientific research they said well you
know you should not cause needless harm
or injury or pain to animals unless
you're doing so in the name of research
and if you cut up an animal while it's
still alive you really find out an awful
lot more than if you wait for it to be
dead before you cut it up so vivisection
the upper crust tended to go with the
vivisectionist because they thought that
was scientific research whereas people
of a no more middling social background
felt that this was inhumane and you have
a the anti-vivisection society splits
from the from the Royal humane society
and and all this has sort of has mirrors
in this area of of humans let's go back
to Spencer Spencer believed that humans
were becoming better and better this was
a very important Creed in the 19th
century held by different people on very
different you know conjectures hey for
Hegel it was purely a spiritual thing
for for Marx it was a class struggle
dialectic that was producing better a
better society not necessarily better
better people for Spencer it was that
people were becoming better because as
they acquired more more knowledge they
passed it on genetically to their
offspring
and that literally each generation could
expect to be superior in to the
preceding generation he made a
distinction between what he called
militant society and industrial society
he said that and it very if it's
analogous but somewhat different from
Marxist distinction between feudal
society and bourgeois society militant
society a grain dispenser was a society
in which people used force to own or
dominate other people and that in the
course of time they naturally rose above
that because as they evolve they
realized that there was something more
humane so that militant society was
destined to pass away and to be replaced
by something vastly better which he
called industrial society obviously not
seeing industrial society and quite
Marxist terms and he felt that in the in
industrial society what you would have
would be everyone being rewarded for
their for their efforts through the
system of market ownership of production
and goods and so on and that this would
reach a point where the state would
wither away in other words he was a pure
capitalist in the sense that capitalism
and the market would not only create an
equitable society equitable within the
with understanding that some people are
you know more capable of achievement
than others but he also believed that
you could do away that with government
so that now Herbert Spencer is being
revived
his reputation that have been shattered
by richard hofstadter in 1944 is being
restored by the libertarian philosophy
in the United States now today yes you
you look at libertarians and they say
well one of the great pioneers a
libertarian thought was Herbert Spencer
because he said that the government has
no intrinsic role in industrial society
the government was important for
militant society but in industrial
society the market provides everything
you need and that other than than
defense you really don't have to have a
government so he said you know there's
no reason for a government to to provide
roads or railroads there's no need for a
government to provide education there's
no need for a government to provide
welfare he praised welfare and he said
that the haves by being more elevated
people will want to give to support the
have-nots so he thought that through
private philanthropies churches or
otherwise the the problem of caring for
the needy in a society will be taken
care of without any government
intervention so from a libertarian point
of view because these are right in line
with you know kind of you know Class A
aim rammed thinking about government of
society
Spencer is right there at the origin so
now it's important from a libertarian
perspective since libertarians are
making a move politically to try and
resurrect Spencer
and that means attacking richard
hofstadter because he's the person who
vilified spencer poor spencer who never
had any idea all this was going to go on
and it doesn't seem to have been a
particularly genial person anyway so now
when you look at libertarian efforts to
rescue Spencer from oblivion you find
first they will point out that his
philosophy was incredibly popular that
he sold a million copies and Hofstadter
did not sell a million copies of all of
his books put together so he was
incredibly popular people in the late
19th century thought his notion of human
progress as being a sort of in electable
product of the actual movement from
generation to generation of the human
species which he called evolution but
not in a Darwinian sense but rather an
old Marcum sense that we get better and
better because better children stand on
the shoulders of better and better
parents due to the inheritance of their
superior characteristics from their
parents so now you'll find that in the
libertarian writings that ha it's
pointed out that Richard Hofstadter was
a member of the Communist Party and that
he was on record
numerous times of saying I hate
capitalism so now some people are
looking on social Darwinism as maybe
social Darwinism was a sort of nasty
label for practices that the Communists
didn't like namely capitalist practices
and so you have people going back and
trying to revisit the late 19th century
and say that Spencer was innocent that
he was simply a a proto libertarian a
social Darwinism did not exist in that
under that name and that the separate
sins of the social Darwinists for
example the genetics the eugenics
philosophy
never really grabbed on anyone and that
what social darwinism maintained was
that a human difference is is wrong
social Darwinism is a in this in the
traditional construction the post
Hofstadter construction it's a failed
error ridden philosophy in which the the
natural equality of humans is being
subverted by the idea that humans evolve
in unequal fashion and so now in this
conservative rethinking you know people
going back and saying well maybe human
inequality should not be you know should
not be assumed to be a bad thing this
may be reminiscent of things just recent
weeks or the issue of human inequality
has been politicized in this country but
it it's quite it's quite broad now of
course all of this took place at a time
when no one had the slightest idea of
what what genetics were known as the
slightest idea what actually happened in
inheritance and the theories of the late
19th century are often based on
extraordinarily flawed and incomplete
and weak assumptions about you know
about the natural world about humans and
animals and plants and yet those
philosophies are still around and they
still they still play a role you people
still feel that that the 19th century
was a great cauldron of
brilliant new thinking and the
deconstruction of that I think is
beginning to be underway perhaps with
Michel Foucault as a pioneer in that and
saying that the scientist of things on
sort of pseudoscience of sexuality or
mental deviance or things like that
inborn criminality and so on that that
kind of pseudo scientific description of
inequality was a perversion of the
Enlightenment rather than a great
accomplishment of the Enlightenment but
then you had something that was going on
in a different direction and it had to
do with with quantification because one
of the one of the great divisions that
arises in the late 19th century is a
division between the idea that you can
determine things through through
quantifying them that you could actually
measure difference in a quantitative
fashion versus the idea that there are
certain things that cannot be measured
in a quantifiable fashion for religious
people this had to do with things
regarding the soul or or divine activity
but there were many other people who
felt that the things that happen in the
mind were not susceptible of of a
quantitative measure is why something
like Columbia's commitment to a mind
brain and behavior future to try and put
Columbia and the cutting age edge of
scientific thought is is actually a
commitment to the idea that you know
quantification
and scientific study is adequate to
understand all theses little late 19th
century this was a big a big division so
you had the birth of sociology at this
time
sociology divides into two into two
camps of that going into the 20th
century particularly by the middle 20th
century become quite strongly opposing
camps you've one camp that believes in
quantification and that increasingly
says that poles and
you know similar measurements of of
human behavior and so forth actually
tell you what the human behavior is they
tell you something I remember years ago
when I first started teaching cc I was
struck by the fact that most of the
thinkers in the second half of the
course would never get tenure today
because none of them were quantifiers
they were having theories about society
humanity and so forth but they didn't
they didn't substantiate them in a
quantity in a quantifiable method so I
thought well we should add a text that
will be a pioneer work in applying
quantification not simply to the economy
which had already been done
but to but to social issues so I signed
a mail durkheim's
book on suicide which is full of graphs
about the rates of suicide in France for
different different times different
places during categories and the
category that that he selects as being a
crucial variable is whether your
Protestant or Catholic do Protestants
commit suicide more often than Catholics
because
why because if they can't confessing in
absolution
they're eaten up with guilt and being
eaten up with guilt they they commit
suicide presumably Jews can commit
suicide even more because they're always
talking about guilt I don't know but it
was it was an example of how
quantification and all my students can
see it a quantification is kind of
garbage in garbage out if it's based
upon assumptions that are that are opera
or E and not necessarily demonstrable so
that when did quantification become
really crucial in some areas it's it's
quite early particularly in those
relating to to psychological behavior of
animals so that the idea of of reflexes
where you ring a bell and the dog
salivates because it has been you've
created a reflex through through it
through exposure and you have that area
of Experimental Psychology dealing with
animals primarily that leads the idea
that you actually can not only predict
behaviors and measure behaviors but you
can instill behaviors through through
this sort of process leading up to old
theories say back in the 60s like the
Skinner box where you would raise an
infant in a box deprived of all human
contact and then you would supply all of
the all of the contacts under
experimental fashion and you would you
know end up with the child that you want
it to have rather than the one that you
were stuck with
this was BF Skinner who was the thinker
on this wrote a book called Walden - a
novel about how perfect society would be
if everyone was brought up in a
completely regimented parentless society
had the idea that you could have guided
bombs during World War two where you
would simply have a you know you'd have
a bomb that would be launched from an
airplane but in order to guide it in the
the front of the bomb you'd have pigeons
and the pigeons would correct the
direction of the bomb as it veered
according to a compass or an altimeter
by pecking no colors as I come up you
know too low peck peck the red pick and
then of course you'd be rewarded with a
you know a bit of corn or something with
this idea of conditioned reflex
you know leads into experimental
experimental psychology the idea of a
social psychology that where you could
determine things by by polling was
initially very very suspect and the the
quantifiers were at odds with the the
more qualitative theorize errs in the
sociological profession throughout the
early 20th century it remains a huge
huge split in this country you know do
polls that are followed minutely by you
know by politicians actually tell you
something or
do they reflect biases that are built
into the questioning that produce
answers that are desired on the part of
the Poehler and of course our efforts to
control all this but the other hand you
had people who argued very strongly
against the idea of quantification and
said that you know when it comes to to
the human spirit - to the things that
make people who they are you cannot
really quantify it this you know right
now for example history departments
still believe that human humans actually
make some difference in what they think
and feel whereas economics and political
science departments are more inclined to
think that everything can be reduced to
quantifiable variables in my field of
Middle East Studies we went through a
huge debate on this back in the 80s and
90s over whether culture makes any
difference whatsoever and in political
science profession which turned against
culture there was a widely held
conclusion that culture is not a
significant variable that a peasant in
Indonesia will behave
Quanah quantitatively in the same way as
a peasant in Brazil or a peasant in in
North Korea given given the same stimuli
or the same the same inputs and
therefore there was no need for people
to learn obscure languages or religions
or cultures so forth all they had to do
was to to run the numbers this kind of
came to an end around you know 1991 or
so and the person most associated with
bringing culture back in was
Samuel Huntington who wrote clash of
civilizations which led increasingly to
the idea that religion really matters
and that you know quantitative variables
like unemployment rates or education
levels or you know budget allocations
for this that or the other are are
important but they're all conditioned by
the religious culture of different
people's so this is this debate reading
into this is that this debate over over
human difference has been going on now
for for a long time you you start back
in 1800 or so and before when it's
assumed humans are different in the same
way that's assumed animals are different
you can classify them you can describe
the differences you don't have to
account for the differences you'd say no
that person is a yellow person that was
a red person one's a black person and
you know the yellows always miss layups
and basketball and the blacks always
stuck the ball and the Reds don't play
the game at all I mean it's you know
those things were considered simply
descriptive because that was how the
natural world was dealt with
particularly the organic world at that
time and it really is in the late 19th
century that you had as you had more and
more discussion of inheritance and the
question of why see if people didn't
hadn't perceived that there was progress
in Europe they might not have tried to
to theorize about why progress occurred
so it was not really the 18th century or
the early 19th century but in this later
period where the Europeans increasingly
felt that they were just just a hell of
a lot better than everyone else in the
world that the issue of Prague
on the issue of the reasons for it
particularly as they would pertain to
two particular social groups or ethnic
groups became more and more an issue and
when you had someone who had come up
with a theory of a natural evolution
from from lesser to better that was
directly related to the transition from
a tort in industrial society which was
the fundamental law and he called it a
law that Spencer was selling along with
it the idea that the rich don't really
need to care much about the poor unless
they happen to have some spare change
this was incredibly popular so Spencer
is a very good representative of his
time in many ways a better
representative of his time than Darwin
is because Darwin's discussion
ultimately dealt with species and human
difference was increasingly thought not
to be a species different difference but
rather to be breed differences
differences between Chihuahuas and Great
Danes rather than the differences
between foxes and Wolverines and whatnot
what Darwin did and Wallace was to say
we can see over very long term how
species came into being and that
ultimately wasn't very interesting
except for creationists who were very
upset by the implied undermining of
divine creation and a short chronology
for the existence of the earth but for
people who were not immersed in that
particular religious debate what Darwin
had to say was of limited applicability
because people really weren't that
interested in species they were
interested in in his descent of man
now did humans evolve from from primates
and that was certainly an interest but
the broad notion of species was less
engaging than the immediate perception
that everybody had of the difference of
breeds so when it comes over social
Darwinism in a sense is NaN not
Darwinism at all
because the the competition is not the
competition between the Fox of the
Wolverine it's a competition between
sheepdogs or maybe a sheepdog on the one
hand and uh you know hunting dog in the
other hand it's it's a competition
between breeds and the survival of the
fittest means the survival of the one
that produces the most utility so this
late 19th century engagement with with
human difference so I point out is well
after the abolition movement has
achieved its main its main achievements
this is not this is not the issue of
slavery this is the issue of human
difference as was increasingly apparent
in imperialism as it became more and
more intensely engaged in in other parts
of the world and interestingly one of
the now just finished this one of the
most clearest manifestations of this
sort of new notion of human difference
was the decision in many many parts of
the colonized world that people should
dress like Europeans because that is
what elevated people did so you can have
imperialism in the 18th century in India
you know Indians not dressing like
Europeans early 19th century in India
India dressed like Europeans but you get
down to
1900 or so and you know we can be
superior if we look like that which
almost is at the level of dog breeds
because one of the hallmarks of dog and
cat breeding was to create a an
appearance that would be like the most
excellent specimens so you see
interesting illustrations where you'll
have for example the end of the
sino-japanese war 1890s you have the
Japanese delegation is all in western
military costumes whereas the Chinese
delegation is wearing you know caps and
you know felt shoes and robes and so
forth and you go 20 years later and the
Chinese officials are all dressing like
like Europeans and you get it almost
everywhere and I think that it has to do
with with these evolving notions of how
to to explain or how to deal with with
human difference and we still haven't
solved these things but I think we'd be
further along if we could simply erase
the second half of the 19th century
which saw such a such an immense flurry
of really dumb ideas